[Musik]
da hab ich mir selbst will jetzt wollen
sie nicht mehr
smalltalk mögen die meisten nicht die
meisten deutschen mögen keinen smalltalk
erbracht wie geht's seine leute sofort
ja wie ja wie gewitter gar nicht
wirklich wissen wie es mir geht ja warum
auch was ist das denn für eine absurde
anspruch an menschen nicht rund 50
personen am tag habe ich auch keine lust
50 mal zu erzählen wie es mir wirklich
geht
er habe auch keine lust von 50 leuten
die supermächte gemütslage zu hören ist
sogar auf realen ich mich selber fühle
wie befindlichkeit fixiert kann man sein
immer genau in sich hineinzuhorchen und
dann immer in der antwort zu verlangen
was für'n stress oder und auf jeder
zweiten wg party findest du jemanden der
smalltalk ablehnen und sich deswegen
supergut vorkommt
ich bin stefan und ich studiere
kulturwissenschaft aber ich sage nicht
kulturwissenschaft denn das ist mir viel
zu unpraktisch
deswegen darf stefan kießling nach
kuhwiese beschreibt werden die erste
assoziation ganz gut die man mit dem
wort kultur wissenschaft verbindet ein
weites feld und wenn man sich dafür sehr
interessiert geht's ein wie die kuh
man muss draufstehen so und stefan
findet smalltalk oberflächlich denn er
hat noch vorgelesen und hält sich
deswegen für super klug deswegen fragt
er mich als einstieg was ist deine
größte angst wirklich stefan ich bin
offiziell nicht mal deinen namen warum
soll ich einem wildfremden so was
erzählen
ich meine ich mag diese gespräche aber
davon war einfach ein bisschen anlauf
ich habe jetzt einfach lust auf
oberflächlichkeit foco ist mir gerade
egal
das einzige was ich mich frage ist was
für eine frisur hatte eine foto vokuhila
es ist mein humor ich bin ein einfacher
mensch der fahren aber vor allem als
kämpfst du wirklich damit klar wenn ich
dir so schonungslos ehrlich antwortet
wie du verlangst aber gut probier s mal
auch stefan du hast meine größte angst
ist
ich habe angst es rauskommt was ich 1996
gemacht habe 12 august heißer sommer im
ferienlager im lausitzer forst gehänselt
wegen meiner akte aber dann ist passiert
hinter dem geräteschuppen
wir waren allein ich habe den steiner
liegen sehen und hören dass mir die
sicherung durchgebrannt weil ich wusste
sofort dass er tot war
ich bin dann unbemerkt zu den anderen
niemand gemerkt haben sie erst ein paar
tage später gefunden ist nicht
herausgekommen
also dass ich es war aber jede nacht
träum ich frank a und wie er über mich
lacht und stefan zufrieden war das jetzt
das richtige thema für das dritte bier
auf einer wg party stefan marx motor nur
aus einem grund nicht er kann es nicht
wenn man smalltalk schlecht macht es ist
das schlimmste der welt wenn man dann
gefragt so hey wie gehts und stefan
antwortet dann sollst mir schon gehen
ja genau genau so antwortete er da ist
er schon der punkt erreicht an dem du
keinen bock mehr hat
aber du machst dann tapfer weiter und
dann erzählt er der andere von der einen
serie
kennst du die und ich sagte nein und
hier muss es gespräche über die serie zu
ende sein der nicht kennen sie ja nicht
smartag ist so etwas wie eine zweite
sprache im hintergrund du fragst wie
geht es dir und der andere sagt gut dass
es die verabredung und du hörst das gut
aber das ist die information dieser am
wenigsten brauchst die anderen
informationen sind das spannende nämlich
wie viel mühe muss sich der andere geben
wenn er gut sagt also wie doll liegt ja
nicht an und einer differenz zur
wahrheit merke ich wie schlecht es
jemandem geht gerade weil es nicht so
wichtig ist was man sagt kann man sich
auf das wie konzentriert ist wie mit
battle rap weil er sowieso klar ist dass
den rapper sagen dass sie geil sind kann
man sich darauf fokussieren wie gut sie
das machen
so also also bis auf einer wg party und
da steht jennifer und fragt sie wie es
ihr geht und sie sagt gut und du hörst
ihr geht es somit und sie will nicht so
gerne drüber reden also guckst du was
sie trinkt
orangensaft okay so und dann sagt man so
bringt sowie eigentlich grundsätzlich
gerne säfte oder es ist einfach nur weil
dir der wodka pur schmeckt und dann
erzählt dir jennifer dass sie wirklich
sehr gerne orangensaft trinkt denn es
ist ihr lieblings saft den hat sie
damals immer bei ihrem opa gedruckt und
dann erzählt sie dir wie es früher war
zusammen mit ihrem opa dann weiß ich
doch nach fünf minuten mehr über
jennifer als wenn ich sie gefragt hätte
was ist deine größte angst es geht doch
nichts oberflächliches als zu denken die
oberfläche hätte keine tiefe im auto ist
auf eine zweite sprache wie bei
zeugnissen steht an da er hat sich sehr
bemüht alle wissen ja das war gefüllt
sodass montag ist eine geheimsprache von
der beide so tun als könnten sie nicht
sprechen
smalltalk ist einer der komplexesten
kulturtechniken die es gibt ja herr du
kannst aber ich kann mit drei sätzen
niemandem vermitteln der sich nicht mit
ihm reden möchte und ihm dabei ein gutes
gefühl geben
es war ein gutes gespräch fand mich hast
du das mit kai das wäre schön wenn sie
das dann für sich behalten das ist klar
auch wenn heute show ja ich auch am
essent zufall in die hand die haben eine
verbindung habe ich das gefühl kann das
sein dass mir beiden eine ganz besondere
verbindung als super ja dann wäre gut
findet dass hier alles mal abonnierst
und ja auch alle videos an koks das wäre
auch gefährlich werden euro krieg pro
klick also hier abo und da die videos so
alles mal alles mal drauf kriegen
deswegen wurde ich habe auch frauen
kinder und zwei babys
und die werden dann geschlachtet sonst
wenn du das nicht abonniert